[Music]
[Music]
well we're actually hitting here
holy crap that was cool
jesus it's so gross you even went in
there
yeah so stop diving into it
[ __ ] she's filling the place with sludge
stay in the air
you better not fall in
hey i'm still here you can still use me
if you want
i can deflect attacks did you know that
not just all about stabbing well i'm
mostly all about stabbing and tethering
but i can also deflect attacks
i'll slice in the damn i'll cut their
heads off
and i'll rip their limbs off do
everything long and i'm cut right into
them i'll cut that
[ __ ] off and eat it you know this
sludge matches your toxic personality
that wasn't even a good one
surprise flesh bag
hey
[Music]
just for you
bet you're just as nice and squishy on
the inside as the rest of them let me
out of bounty hunter
wow we're having our first real boss
fight together
i'm impressed you made it this far my
aunt soldiers are extremely strong
honestly i don't think they were we're
new at this and it was pretty easy to
kill them all if i'm going out i'm
taking you with me
[ __ ] just stay alive i think she's
basically done for
[Music]
you